oh well good morning again so i'm just
going to know read ejaculator
declaration of results and I need to
work my way through the formal language
here I Gordon Mitchell being the acting
returning officer for the Great Yarmouth
constituency hereby give notice the
number of votes didn't freeze candidate
at the said election is as follows allen
kristi gray you kept ten thousand two
hundred and seventy james michael joyce
Liberal Democrat 1030 Brandon Kenneth
Lewis the Conservative Party candidate
19,000 and 89 Lara Caroline Norris
Labour Party twelve thousand nine
hundred and thirty-five Samuel George
Townley cannabis is safer than alcohol
167 hurry Lee Webb Green Party 978 the
number of ballot papers rejected was as
follows want of official mark 143 voting
for more candidates and reveille
concedes 13 writing or marble ridge
vortac identified nil unmarked or void
for uncertainty for giving a total of
160 and I do hereby declare that Brandon
Kenneth Lewis is Julie elected
thank you I'd like to thank the
returning officer and the entire team of
work so tirelessly tirelessly since I
know very very early as the morning as
many of the volunteers over and have now
got to come back in just a few hours for
the local government count as well so I
won't say too much I don't say thank you
to the entire team and of course the
police and everybody who's worked so
hard today to make sure that right
across great yarmouth everybody got a
chance to use their democratic right to
vote and did so in a really work well
run and professional manner to thanks to
the team on a personal level I want to
thank all of the volunteers work so hard
with me over the last few months and
indeed the last few years and
particularly to my wife and family who
have been fantastic support right from
the very beginning what I would say is
it is a real honor to represent a
constituency as fantastic as great
yarmouth we've achieved a lot over the
last few years with increasing
investment but there is more that I've
said we need to do and I will continue
to fight to make sure we get the
infrastructure of the education and the
health service that we need that we want
we deserve in great yarmouth and to
continue to build on that strong
economic base to make sure that's also
creating the jobs for everybody in great
yarmouth and growing our economy locally
thank you very much to everybody in
Great Yarmouth I can assure you I will
continue to give one hundred percent for
great yard that I will always remember
as I have worked hard over the last five
years to make very very clear great
yarmouth alexa me great yarmouth comes
first I will fight for great yarmouth
thank you